Salut, aujourd'hui on est le 9 avril !
Ça veux dire que c'est la 100ème vidéo de l'année.
Je me suis quand même dit que c’était sympa que l'on fasse un point tous ensemble.
C'est le jour du point !
Sur ces 100 vidéos écoulées.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
J'ai des petites nouvelles croustillante à vous donner à la fin.
Mais d'abord je vais vous dévoiler les chiffres de la chaîne.
On a dépassé le million !
Pas le million d'abonnés, mais le million de minutes regardé.
On est à un million soixante mille minutes regardé sur la chaîne.
Et en terme de vues, ça se traduit par environ 402 000 vues.
Donc tout confondu les vidéos ont était regardé 402 000 fois.
Alors après on pourrais se dire, oui mais il y en a qui ont 402 000 vues sur une seule vidéo !
C'est vrai et c'est vraiment cool pour eux.
Mais je me réjouis quand même d'avoir ça sur l'intégralité de la chaîne, c'est hyper motivant.
Au moment où j'enregistre cette vidéo, on viens de passer les 12 000 abonnés.
Donc depuis le 1er janvier, vous êtes 12 000 à m'avoir rejoint ici.
Soit spontanément
soit peux être dans les recherches
soit en voyant dans la vidéo que l'on a tourné avec Pierre Croce
soit dans la vidéo que l'on a tourné aussi avec Lætitia.
Je sais qu'il y a des gens de la chaîne le corps, la maison, l'esprit qui m'ont rejoint, c'est cool.
Peux être un jour il faudrait que je parle du BIO, pour vous
mais je ne sais pas si l'on mentalise le BIO...
Il y a eu 16 000 pouces en l'air de déposé sur les vidéos
et il y a eu également 237 pouces en bas dans les vidéos.
Ah je vous ai dit, je vous dit tout !
Il y a 642 personnes qui sont partis.
Sans un mot.
Sans une explication.
Même pas un petit "first" d'adieux...
Je plaisante, mais si un jour vous décider de vous désabonner.
Je serais très intéressé de lire dans vos commentaires pourquoi !
Je sais bien que l'on peut pas plaire à tous le monde.
Tous les sujets que je traite ne plaisent pas à tous le monde.
Mais ce serais très intéressant de savoir.
Pourquoi une personne désire se désabonner.
Mais ça ne veux pas dire qu'il faut partir...
Qu'on soit bien d'accord avec ça quand même.
Et puis en moyenne, il y a un peu prêt 100 personnes qui rejoigne la Team Mentalo
en s'abonnant à la chaîne chaque jours.
En moyenne le nombre de vues par jours est de 10 000 vues sur toutes les vidéos confondu.
D'ailleurs je me marre, je me dit que ce qui arrive aujourd'hui se disent:
Ah, il y a 100 vidéos à regarder ?
Je sais que vous ne les regardez pas toutes.
Puisque des fois dans les commentaires que vous me mettez
vous demandez, si je vais faire ceci ou cela et ça a déjà était fait.
N'hésitez pas à regarder dans les playlists.
Parfois, des vidéos que vous aimeriez voir...
Bah on déjà été faite, en janvier, en février ou en mars !
Voilà, vous savez tout de moi !
Concernant les chiffres.
Je parle pas de mes mensurations, on est bien d'accord.
J'ai subi des formations au YouTube Space.
Sur le "Monter solo", sur d'autres choses, j'ai fais les "Happy hours".
J'ai rencontré un peu tout le monde là-bas, ils sont vraiment cool !
Ils m'aident beaucoup également avec la "Creator academy"
Ça me donne plein de pistes de travail en fait.
Pour améliorer la chaîne, améliorer la qualité des vidéos, le contenu.
La manière de vous présenter tout ça.
Mercredi dernier, j'ai tourné une série de 7 vidéos au YouTube Space.
Avec comme thème : Le Rubik's Cube !
C'est une série de 7 vidéos qui vous apprendra à résoudre un Rubik's Cube en moins de 2 minutes.
Avec seulement 5 choses à retenir !
J'ai une hantise depuis qu'on a commencé tous ensemble le 1er janvier.
C'est de tomber malade et de plus pouvoir fournir les vidéos pendant une journée.
Donc le jour où je serais vraiment malade au point de pas réussir à faire de vidéos.
Je vous mettrai ces vidéos là.
Ou si je tombe pas malade, parce que c'est pas le but non plus.
Je prendrais peut-être une semaine de vacances au milieu de l'été
et je sais déjà que vous préféreriez que je sois malade
parce que c'est pas l'été qu'on a envie d'apprendre à faire du Rubik's Cube.
Quand on a commencé à faire le Mental Vlog au 1er janvier.
Il y avait un peu près, une personne qui nous rejoignait chaque jour.
Maintenant, on en est à 100 par jour comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure.
Donc il fallait que je me fixe un nouvel objectif !
Le nouvel objectif, je vais vous en parler juste à la fin.
Teasing de ouf !
Je viens de m'apercevoir que ma braguette était ouverte
Et je me dis tiens, heureusement qu’aujourd’hui j'ai serré le cadrage !
Je vais peut-être vous solliciter plus souvent alors hésitez pas à me rajouter sur Twitter ou sur Facebook.
C'est là, où je poste le plus souvent les questions.
Par exemple l'autre jour, j'ai fais une énigme.
Enfin c'est plus une embrouille de logique qu'une énigme.
J'aimerais bien savoir si vous en voulez plus souvent.
Ce genre de questions, je vais les poser sur Twitter et sur Facebook.
Et si vous voulez qu'on se retrouve le code c'est #TeamMentalo.
Pour être sûr que je vois les messages des recherches avec ce Hashtag là.
Vous êtes nombreux et nombreuses à me demander ce que je vais faire à partir du 1er janvier prochain !
Puisque cette année, c'était un défi de faire une vidéo par jour du 1er janvier au 31 décembre.
366 vidéos.
Et apparemment ça vous stress de savoir ce que je vais faire après.
Moi aussi ça me stress, en fait j'en sais rien.
Je me suis pris au jeu à fond.
Je prend énormément de plaisir à faire ça !
Et c'est vraiment cool de vous savoir derrière.
Je pensais pas que ça apportais autant de choses...
Vous m'apportez beaucoup.
C'est pour ça que je vous dis souvent merci dans les commentaires, c'est très sincère.
Parce que j'ai bien conscience que si les abonnés augmentent c'est aussi parce que vous partagez, je suppose...
Vous parlez de la chaîne...
C'est juste incroyable, j'ai l'impression d'avoir 12000 amis.
Donc l'année prochaine, je n'arrêterais pas, je continuerais
je sais pas comment, je ne sais pas sous quel forme.
Mais ce qu'est sûr c'est que je vais pas m'arrêter comme ça cache du jour au lendemain
Et en même temps j'aimerais reprendre le temps de faire des vidéos mentalisantes
comme je faisais l'année dernière.
J'en avais fait 6 comme ça en faite !
J'ai commencé YouTube avec ça.
C'était ni plus ni moins des jeux de mentalismes ou de magie mais interactif !
A travers l'écran.
J'avais lancé ça, il y a un peu plus d'un an, c'était un défi aussi.
Par contre je mettais trois jours entre avoir l'idée, le tourner, l'écrire, le monter...
Si ça vous dit, je vais essayer d'en refaire sur cette chaîne.
Bah dites moi dans les commentaires.
Et le défi, c'est quoi le défi, c'est quoi le prochain objectif?
Le premier objectif c'était les 1000 abonnés, on avait fais une FAQ.
Le deuxième objectif, j'avais quasiment multiplié par 3, c'était à 2500.
Et c'était pour le live.
Pour le prochain objectif, je met la barre très très haut, beaucoup plus haut.
Mais je vais vous expliquer pourquoi !
Le prochain défi, c'est la barre des 50 000 !
Donc c'est quasiment 5 fois le nombre d'abonnés qu'on a aujourd'hui
C'est beaucoup, c'est énorme...
Je suis même pas sûr qu'on atteignent ça cette année !
Je suis même pas sûr qu'on atteignent ça un jour !
Mais ce que je veux faire nécessite de mettre la barre à ce niveau là.
A la base, je voulais faire un meet-up, je voulais qu'on se rencontre.
Et vous êtes peut-être pas sans savoir si vous suivez la chaîne que je suis en train d'écrire mon nouveau spectacle !
C'est encore un travail sur la réflexion, sur la recherche.
Y'a un point commun avec le spectacle actuel.
C'est que ça sera toujours du mentalisme et ça sera toujours fait d'une manière drôle où on se marrera tout au long du spectacle.
Et quand on aura atteint les 50 000 abonnés.
J'organiserais une soirée, une soirée où je vous présenterais tout le travail que j'ai fais sur le nouveau spectacle !
Ce sera pas le nouveau spectacle
Ce sera en faite, des phases de test en exclusivité pour vous, avec vous.
Où je vais essayer des idées de numéro que j'ai écris depuis le mois de janvier.
Tout sera inédit !
Ça sera 100% inédit.
Et après on boira un verre et on discutera en faite du spectacle.
Je vous demanderais votre avis, peut-être même je ferais un petit questionnaire.
C'est un vrai gros gros challenge, j'en parle avec hâte et beaucoup de stress
Mais je me dis que ça sera une grande première
de présenter un travail inédit comme ça aux personnes qui me suivent.
Avec qui je communique quotidiennement
et d'avoir leur retour en direct et de boire un coup derrière ça.
Tout ça est pas défini à 100%.
Parce que jusqu'à 50 000, j'ai encore le temps.
Ça sera pas le Meet-up, ça sera le Mental-up
Si vous faites parti des abonnés, vous pouvez me le faire savoir en laissant un petit : pouce en l'air !
Comme ça je serais que le message a été reçu.
Si vous ne faites pas parti des abonnés, vous pouvez vous abonner !
Et laisser un petit pouce en l'air et commenter...
Je lirai votre message
Vous pouvez demander aux autres, je lis tous les messages !
Tous ! Ça me prend de plus en plus de temps mais je le fais !
Demain on est dimanche
donc demain je vais vous expliquer un tour pour que vous puissiez bluffer, vos amis, votre famille etc à votre tour !
Profitez bien de ce samedi
Rendez-vous demain à 11h pour le prochain Mental Vlog!
Ciao !